voici mon gros my life oui je sais
j'arrive un peu après tout le monde mais
le temps que les infos monde chez nous
aussi le gie plus rien mais je voulais
quand même vous raconter ma vie
moi je m'appelle aristo clegg comme mon
grand-père si si et vous devez plus me
connaître sous le nom de platon son prof
de gym qui m'a surnommé comme ça à cause
de ma carrière
oui parce que platon ça veut dire large
en grec ancien j'ai grandi à athènes non
c'était pas comme ça
voilà merci et j'étais plutôt sportif je
sais pas mal de lui
non c'est pas ça non plus la lutte voila
voila je faisais de la lutte voilà et
j'ai même gagné une médaille aux jeux
olympiques
et ouais ça existait déjà ensuite vous
voulez être un bon citoyen donc j'ai
fait un peu de politique
mais j'ai vite abandonné parce que ce
qui dilue j'ai été un peu excessif bref
ça m'a dégoûté
à côté de ça je faisais la poésie de la
poésie héroïque mais en comparant ma
poésie à celle de maire je la trouvais
nul vous savez celui qui avait lié à des
l'odyssée du coup j'ai tout jeté au feu
ensuite je me suis mis au jour tragique
j'ai même fait une pièce et j'allais la
faire jouer parce que je les ai
rencontrés
j'avais 20 ans il allait changer ma vie
il s'appelait socrates
il était grand fort et moche il était
très très moche
il avait 68 ans mais qu'est-ce qui
parlait bien de grandes phrases le mot
juste il était très intelligent il
m'avait séduit la partir de ce moment je
lis est complètement tombée la tragédie
pour faire comme lui de la philosophie
secrète c'était un ancien opitz et des
fantassins lourdement armés qu'est-ce
qu'il était puissant ils prenaient
souvent par derrière
non non non non non non non non il
m'apprenait souvent par derrière ses
discours voilà c'est ça que je voulais
dire il m'apprenait souvent par derrière
ces discours imposer les questions
justes j'étais devenu son disciple et je
notais tout tout ce qu'il me disait
en fait je suis un peu revenu à ma
passion première la tragédie en écrivant
comme des pièces mme avec pour
personnage principal
socrates c'était chouette mais
malheureusement ça n'a duré que huit ans
socrates a eu un procès il a été
condamné à voir du poison
il avait beaucoup disciples de saint
amand mais pas moi je n'étais pas là
j'ai fait dire à mes personnages dans
une de mes oeuvres que j'étais malade
mais je crois que c'est la pierre
excuses qu'on puisse trouver
il manque à ce moment là j'ai vite fait
avec des potes à mes gars une vive on
peut se perdre facilement
je suis parti en italie en libye est
enfin en egypte j'ai vu beaucoup de gens
beaucoup de paysages et surtout j'ai
beaucoup écrit durant cette période
durant toute ma vie j'aurai quand même
voyage et 12 en méditerranée j'adore les
voyages avant un retour à athènes je
suis finalement repartir en italie
sicile la famille c'est comme ça qu'on
dit non c'est là que j'ai rencontré dion
c'est devenu un mets meilleur ami
c'était le beau-frère du tyran qui
régnait là-bas mais le voyage s'est mal
passé et j'ai été vendue en tant
qu'esclave pas hyper hyper cool comme
situation je vous avoue un j'ai connu
mieux heureusement pendant la vente un
ami à nice et risma reconnu et m'a
libéré d'une beaucoup de chance il m'a
acheté pour 20 min alors j'ai pas tout
conversion 1000 euros mais avec 20 mine
à l'époque on pouvait s'acheter un
jardin j'étais de nouveau à athènes
je voulais tout faire pour transmettre
le savoir j'ai alors pu fonder
l'académie j'avais 40 ans j ai pas mal
de monde à l'académie y avait par
exemple pamphile le maître des piqûres
ou mon ami xénon crac mon corps ce
paisible
mon neveu ça se passait super bien il y
avait plein de gens et même des femmes
vous rendez compte pour l'époque
et puis il ya eu ce statut
je n'ai pas une relation évidente avec
lui en fait certes il était intelligent
mais je sais pas il était très
superficiel il faisait vachement
attention à ses habits et chaussures et
puisse couper les cheveux je comprenais
pas trop l'intérêt
je l'appelais parfois mon poulain parce
que le poulain donne des coups de pieds
à sa mère quand il a bu sont les ébats
aristote je le trouvais ingrat comme le
poulain je vais pas sûr que poulin et
garder la même signification aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs un jour j'avais 80 ans je me
promenais tranquillement seul parce que
aristote m'a plu en embuscade avec des
amis à lui il a commencé à me poser une
série de questions pour se moquer de moi
en abusant de la vieillesse pendant un
temps je me promenais que dans mon
jardin où vous comprenez pourquoi je
l'appelais mon poulain et puis un soir
de la même année
je vais me coucher et je me suis jamais
arrivé j'ai vu d'en haut sur la
philosophie devenu au fil des ans au fil
des siècles
au fil des millénaires et je suis fière
qu'elle puisse apprendre si facilement
en plus maintenant tout le monde peut
essayer de faire son académie en faisant
des vidéos sur internet par exemple
d'ailleurs j'en connais un qui ont fait
découlent et si j'étais là je m'abonne
ray pour sûr il a un ami qui dessinent
super bien max a fait feu
enfin moi je veux pas platon dur ça bah
moi non plus mais pour traverser jouer
que les gens et warta chaîne à hockey
sont pas il s'appelle thomas finas effet
des animations sympas sur ces deux
chaînes pipeau l'ata et tom et judo tout
est dans la description
bref tant qu'il y aura des gens vous
regardez ce genre de vidéos la
philosophie ne se sera jamais existé
merci à vous
ah oui si je vous ai pas parlé de femmes
c'est pas que j'ai oublié c'est juste
que je rester célibataire toute ma vie
en tout cas cette vidéo vous a plu
n'hésitez pas à partager bisous